let's talk a little bit about the water
cycle which we're all familiar with in
fact we're all part of the water cycle
every moment of our lives we might not
fully appreciate it so let's just jump
in the cycle I'll start with evaporation
so we could start with the surface of
the ocean here or this river or this
lake and at any given moment there's
going to be water evaporating off of
that sir off of that surface water
molecules that were in their liquid
state liquid state they just have enough
energy to bounce away and go into the
gas state and water in a gaseous state
we call vapor water vapor water water
vapor and so that water vapor it is
going to rise likely with the the air
that has been heated on the surface due
to the Sun and there's other more
complex dynamics at play but as it rises
and as the overall temperature cools
that water vapor will condense into
little droplets it'll condense around
little tiny air particles little
particles of dust that you can't even
see with your eye and that's what forms
clouds so this is this is little
droplets little droplets so the water is
actually back to the liquid form they're
not individual water molecules anymore
they're now getting there they're now
able to interact with each other and
they they're condensing around these
little microscopic dust particles to
form these water droplets and if it's
cold enough they might also form small
ice crystals and that's what clouds are
and we see here they're talking about
transportation you can have these clouds
we obviously if you look outside you see
clouds those clouds are moving with the
wind and so they could be moving all of
those droplets with with the overall
wind and when those droplets get heavy
enough they will precipitate they will
precipitate down now they could
precipitate back into where we started
they could go back to the ocean there or
you could go on to a mountain here and
since that and that since if the air is
cold enough and if you have the right
conditions that precipitation might be
snow and it might stay snow right over
there
or ice but then eventually things might
might warm up or they might not warm up
but when they if they do warm up well
then they would melt and then they would
they would be snow melt runoff and
that's what you're seeing there if that
rain is falling in this area so and
let's say it's not cold enough for it to
be snow so that we are talking about
rain well most of that water is actually
going to percolate down into into the
soil so most of it goes down we look
around us and we see these rivers and
lakes and we say oh wow there's a lot of
water there but it turns out there's
actually a lot more water inside the
ground and obviously in the ocean and
we'll talk about that in a little bit
and so you have these you have all of
this water that forms in these
underground these underground aquifers
here but some of it also ends up in
these lakes and these lakes are usually
in a situation where the the ground is
all either already saturated water or
there's the right top types of rocks so
it can contain the water up here and
similarly rivers are formed by runoff
it's you know snowmelt runoff can
famously form rivers and in general if
you see a creek or a river near your
house that especially when it rains it
fills up not a good indication that the
groundwater is already saturated and so
things are running off into that river
and so that in general is the water
cycle you have evaporation it condenses
into clouds it eventually precipitates
and it keeps going round and round and
round now of course there's other actors
at play you have things like plants
plants will take up water from the upper
soil as far as the plants roots go and
it will use that water to transport
nutrients down from the soil up into the
leaves it also uses that water as part
of the photosynthesis process that we've
studied in in many videos and a lot of
that water gets transpired it gets
transpired out so once again this is
transpiration essentially evaporation
out of the leaves of the water over here
you see this word supplement sub
sublimation that's going straight from
the solid form of water ice into the gas
form of water or
water vapor and this will happen in
situations where you well it's cold and
it's very very very very very dry and
and you have in general low-pressure and
so right when instead of going into the
liquid state right then the water
molecules just start back just leaving
as water vapor now and of course you
know I said we're part of it well how
are we part of it well we will drink
some of this fresh water our bodies are
actually mostly water are the cells in
our bodies or 70% water we you know
everything we study in biology water is
a is a key environment for all of these
things to occur and then we use that
water and then we will we will get that
water out of our body and then it
continues on is part of this water cycle
now one thing that that I find really
interesting as a as an organism that is
dependent on fresh water when people say
fresh water we're talking about water
without salt as opposed to salt water so
we really need this water that's in the
fresh water in this lakes or in this
river or we might dig wells so that we
can get the water out of these aquifers
it actually turns out that very little
of the overall water in the in the world
is fresh water and so let me show you
this chart over here I always knew that
but I didn't fully appreciate how little
was fresh water so of all the water on
our planet
97.5 percent is salt water for the most
part in our oceans only two-and-a-half
percent is fresh water and even of that
two and a half percent fresh water very
little of it is what we traditionally
associate fresh water the lakes and the
rivers when I think of fresh water I
mean to say let me go to a lake or river
that that's stuff that we could
potentially drink but most of it is
actually in glaciers and permanent snow
cover so it's it's ice snow that is just
not melting and it makes you think about
what would happen if this stuff were to
melt and then you also have groundwater
which we could have access to that's why
people drink dig wells so we're talking
about
well groundwater includes soil moisture
swamp water and permafrost but very
little of the water is actually in lakes
and rivers which I personally find fast
it wasn't obvious to me before I frankly
saw this Sothis chart now another really
interesting thing is how long on average
water molecules might stay in different
parts of this water cycle so you know
going back here you can imagine that a
water molecule could stay for a very
long time in the ocean especially you
know it's going to be moving around
depending on ocean currents and
temperature and all of that but you
could imagine it could it could stay in
that liquid form in that ocean for a
very long time and maybe it spends a
shorter amount of time in a cloud and
people have actually studied this which
I find fascinating I'd be curious to
figure out how they actually got this
data but this is the average residence
time for water molecules and you can see
here that water can stay in glaciers in
permafrost for a very long time we're
talking it could be up to ten thousand
years and these are all rough numbers it
could stays ground water anywhere from
two weeks to ten thousand years I guess
depending on how isolated that
groundwater is it could be in the oceans
and seas is saltwater for four thousand
years and we can look at all of these
all the way to within an or with in
living organisms it'll stay about on
average a water molecule will last about
a week in the atmosphere so that's
getting water vapor turning into a cloud
precipitating down on average one and a
half weeks and once again these are
averages it doesn't mean that every
water molecule will stay exactly one and
a half weeks in the atmosphere but it's
a pretty interesting thing to think
about it and it gives you a little bit
more sense of well one where all the
water is and how it all works together
with the water cycle